as sports science and nutrition is
become important that's been in kind of
my generation we know our bodies we know
different people work in different ways
the more we understand that the more you
can tailor specific products for people
and their needs the most important
product in sports nutrition that I've
used from the career is Regal is having
the right mix of protein and
carbohydrate immediately after I finish
the stage you see the rider crossing the
line well you don't see what's gone from
the cross the line to see in the
newspapers and that's going on the
podium it's doing anti-doping control
its interviews with different TVs
different newspapers it's seeing the
fans and it can be a good few hours
before you get closer Hotel does it soon
after you finish as you can you need to
replenish what your body's taken out
during that race and what you need to
recover for the day after and really
always just being perfect it's just
austere as soon as you cross the finish
line
[Music]